greetings from podcast Ville its
Thursday the 11th of [ __ ] April
the Church of what's happened now is
brought to you by one of my favorite
companies of all time on it supplements
that work from shroom tech to alpha
brain to shroom tech immune in sport to
the protein powders you know me I've
done one on it for six seven eight years
even before the podcast started and the
Alpha brain or make you tip-top Magoo
with a hundred percent money-back
guarantee so let honor calm right now
look at this list of supplements if
there's something you like on the way
I'll press in church and get 10% off
delivered to your house you can never
leave the story they're gonna know vite
nothing that's how it works the church
is also brought to you by and I love to
welcome let me explain something to you
I love the city of Pittsburgh
I love the City of Buffalo I love
Lexington Kentucky there's a lot of
places I love I love Paducah Kentucky
but there's only one problem
there's no direct flights this
connecting flights you know the
connecting flight does to my back it
kills me especially when I gotta get off
the out of the car out of the plane and
drive another for you 45 minutes it just
destroys my back I got something sent to
me and it is tremendous quality
terr-berish an in recession table okay
like I said this is gonna sound a little
strange guys but hanging upside down is
great for your back I got the thing sent
to me last week when I got off the plane
in Pittsburgh my wife said we got it
sent let's hook it up let me tell you
somebody hung yesterday and the day
before and today my back feels
tremendous you know why cuz Tina help us
decompress your spine and like magic
boom the pain goes away it's simple just
hang upside down and let gravity do the
work what I'm going to do is this okay
teen inversion tables have thousands of
reviews on Amazon with an average 4.9
star rating and they have a special
offer just for the church savages for
limited time we're gonna give you $70
off a teeter inversion table plus our
lives worth of bonus accessories go to
Tina calm slash Church you also get free
shipping free returns and a 60 day money
back guarantee no risk to try it out
remember you can only get $70 off a
teeter inversion table plus free bonus
accessories by
going to telecom / church that's
t-dot-com / church again that's Tina
calm / church and get upside down you
bad [ __ ] take this mule Lee
Tony hate you from the [ __ ] house
what's up my man I can't call it great
to have you back yeah quit a while and
[ __ ] I did not know you were heavy Pink
Floyd fan huge Pink Floyd fan no between
you and I yeah do you like the Syd
Barrett [ __ ] really honestly not that
much oh my god Yoko Ono jump up and down
one of ukulele yeah it was that like
when people came up to me there were
certain types of music when I was
growing up there when people came up to
me they said they really like this I
would look at them to say really or is
it that you trying to [ __ ] be cool
right cuz this is garbage
yeah he was trying to be cool let me
know but the early Pink Floyd is like
Yoko Ono it's like nails on a [ __ ]
board yeah you know I didn't start
coming around till I wasn't hit the pink
floyd as much as Led Zeppelin Sabbath
and then when I took a hit acid and I
went to see a midnight movie when I was
growing up midnight movies were a huge
Tony Hinchcliffe every movie theater had
two movies the what's the movie were
people yell scream Oh Rocky Horror
he had rocky armor and then the other
one would have a classic or rock concert
song remains the same and one of the
ones I went to see was Pink Floyd live
at Pompeii oh yeah I know that yeah DVD
yeah we want to see that in the movies
you know on a hit of [ __ ] NASA don't
meddle in that whoo juice or whatever
the [ __ ] we did we went in then I'm
believing they're going there something
to that Pink Floyd and but I had Dark
Side of the Moon I had dark side I'm
only eighth grade yeah because I like
the song money and I told Lea I used to
have the McDonald's all-american
basketball poster on my wall had a
picture dr. J about the slam at another
picture or example that was a backwards
picture it was taken so everybody was
opposite Jimmy Page was really a righty
in the picture he was a lefty right was
the weirdest picture it was a very
rare I'd done on my wall and this kid
Vinnie Lynch God rest his soul took me
and I took a hit of [ __ ] blotter acid
I was maybe freshman year just like took
a gonna blot acid like five or six beers
I got [ __ ] up and I went home and I
laid down and I had the eight-track to
dark side and one that had one of those
portable 8-track planes and I put dogs
some of the thing was in my ear and that
under under the eye the pianos his [ __ ]
and that's the first time I really
started tripping out of posters I mean
that thing you could play that for
somebody who's stone sober
you got like he get he used to when he
would get me really high on on edibles
and then bong hits he put that stuff on
and it's like I understand like you say
it's like made that trip it's terrifying
it's like it gets your heart rate going
like it's not it doesn't really sound
like music to me [ __ ] you up planes like
have you listened to those things sober
though
yeah I've listened to it sober I I mean
it's interesting but I just start that I
started thinking about when I'm high and
it gets me gets me all riled up yeah
that's too many edibles that's just the
edibles yeah you're having flashbacks
yeah I loved as a young kid getting that
[ __ ] I yeah I'm putting that on to
test my wits world that's how it started
with me in high school when I started
getting stoned with me on my buddies I
mean that was it it was on like Donkey
Kong and then you know Pink Floyd was
really the first start I ever
appreciated Pink Floyd sort of got me
into tarantino which got me and you know
respecting art you know it was Floyd and
Tarantino that was it when I was in high
school I remember our senior year we had
like our rivalry week or whatever where
you know you hang out with the buddies
and all this and each night everybody
crashes at everybody else's house like
eat okay so Wednesday's Tony's night and
I put together this whole thing where me
and the buddies watched was Super
Troopers and then I showed them Pink
Floyd matched up with Wizard of Oz now
back then you know you had to literally
have the frickin VHS or whatever of
Wizard of Oz and you had to have a
separate CD player to play the two
things and you had to match them up
yourself it's not like you can go on
YouTube you just type in WI Z and the
rest pops up now and you could watch it
matched up but that stuff matches up and
it's one of the great anomalies one of
the great mysteries to me up there with
DB Cooper and everything is how the hell
does that stuff match up it matches up
lyrically it matches up video wise
you've done that right I saw it when
they that [ __ ] first came out and I was
blown away it's ridiculous that's not
something that it's [ __ ] crazy yeah
cuz like either they made that album
knowing what they were doing and sort of
like oh we need this to match up with
Wizard of Oz like why would they do that
but lyrically time wise all these things
for 52 minutes you know it ends with her
putting her head to the Tin Man's heart
and it ends with that heartbeat you know
all this stuff and it's what the
best-selling album of all time next to
the Eagles Greatest Hits or whatever and
then it's Dark Side of the Moon which
says a lot because you know they've
always painted Pink Floyd they being
like you know whatever media and people
as this just psychedelic band but you
ask any musician who their favorite bass
player you know whatever is they tell
you Roger Waters Pink Floyd you know and
that's the thing I think with Sid Sid
got a bad reputation I think cuz he
didn't want to play anything mainstream
and those guys always wanted to make
money and have hits they're like we
could have hit yeah this guy's troll
that walks against the wall his hand
with a hammer and yelling it was tough
to listen to that when it's really weird
when I speak to people who are high up
in music which is not a lot and this
enemy who holds your favorite guitarist
like I love Jimmy Page okay I love I
think Jimmy Page is brilliant the song
remains the same proves it I love that
melancholic guitar player I love Randy
Rhoads but the guy that splits my heart
in half with his guitar there's been two
guys that's David Gilmour and Eric
Clapton yep
McGee on that and that same [ __ ]
school or guitar playing
I I could lie to you and tie all this
[ __ ] my first experience of Pink Floyd's
Dark Side a book and then I was lost in
this avid stones who world and whatever
and I started hanging out with this dude
he had a shed and he put it on [ __ ]
animals okay now if you're high and
you're not ready for animals it will
take you [ __ ] down yeah and I was
groomed on animals to the point that if
my daughter's around
I put dogs on yeah if she's playing like
she plays junga in my office on which
like Django together
how about to put dogs on yeah and when
she hears the dogs barking and she
reacts to me and she asked me what that
is and I tell her there's three types of
people in the world dogs pigs and
[ __ ] sheep
you got a pig one you could be a pig and
hang up like Harvey Weinstein he could
be a [ __ ] dog and he just breaks it
down to it lyrically in the beginning
you got to be crazy you got to have a
real need you got to sleep on your toes
when you're off the street you gotta be
able to pick out the easy meat with your
eyes closed now that tells you the story
your life right there you're gonna go on
to the jumble that better be your
[ __ ] Monica before you leave the
house that's it it's not a [ __ ] day
painting it out for you you know I don't
even know what the second verse is but I
know it's like [ __ ] oh you end up
with cancer and you're [ __ ] listening
to you're on a hit of acid your mind is
[ __ ] somewhere else and this guy's
telling you that if you don't attack you
know you're gonna end up with [ __ ]
dying an old man of cancer and Florida
and [ __ ] and you're listening to this
and all sudden it takes this [ __ ]
guitar this Gilmour comes in here these
dogs barking and in those days you got
monotone speakers so the speaker's the
barking will come out of two speakers in
two different times it would blow your
[ __ ] brains off see got the lyrics
right like that's a guitar guitar
creator the guy who's writing it is the
bass player who and basically their
rivalry Roger Waters and David Gilmour
never got along they couldn't stand each
other but that's what fed the band they
were competing with each other oh you
think the bass line to money
is gonna be what steals the show wait
till you see what I go cook up in the
room I'm gonna go write the guitar solo
you son of a [ __ ] right so this
competition this healthy competition
made it so that they're literally trying
to steal the show
he writes comfortably numb' Gilmore's
like well I'll go write the guitar solo
then they did those things separately
like sort of sorted together but really
separately Gilmore would go off and do
whatever and figure that out so you got
the lyrics you got the guitar you got
the bass drums whatever sure they got a
drummer the written by the bass player
but another crazy fun fact is they were
the first band to ever apply colors or
decorate a stage it used to just be a
black hurt that was it it wasn't there
wasn't no inflatables lasers colors
there was no screens they weren't no
band was showing anything behind them
that wasn't a thing it was listen to the
music watch us play so you you when you
factor in everything into this day and
not only back in the late 70s and 80s
were they spending more money than
everybody else to put on a big
production but to this day I've got to
go see Roger Waters at the Staples
Center this most recent time with my
friend tall Wilkenfeld amazing bass
player one of the best in the world
and she loves comedy her and I made
friends and she's in deep with everyone
in music everyone looks up to her turns
out at the end of the show Roger Waters
we were in the green room with everybody
that's in the band and everything but
Rogers not not there he has his own
separate green room with like chocolate
fountains and everything like stuff you
just dream like stuff you hearing
imagine made-up stories and but the
point is is we were so in that she ended
up running into the guy you know in the
middle of the big Staples Center that
like runs everything and it cuz like
he's like hey tall and she's like hey
bump up a bun and I listen to them and
he was telling her like you see that up
there that's a that's an extra whatever
it was 15 million in speakers that they
brought in that they just have hanging
from the top of the Staples Center like
extra extra super crazy sound that even
you know she didn't know about it was
like inside information basically like
they still to this day are pushing it to
blow
people's minds away to shreds well that
was the problem why they didn't or the
wall they did the six dates or in Philly
or New York and they did the other six
dates and [ __ ] because the production
was too expensive they wanted no I paid
$15 for those tickets that's crazy you
know I think the top ticket was $28
maybe 25 so they broke even on those
shows you know I read somewhere where
they basically broke even they happened
tour that it was first off if you watch
everything May there was a couple bands
between I say 69 to 80 before cocaine
took over this great country of ours
everything was pretty much every band if
you watch the videos and all that [ __ ]
even Woodstock it's made because they
assume that you're tripping if you watch
the song remains the same there's colors
and that is there's sketches of him
climbing up the wall and touching hours
to Crowley and the guitar is in the
[ __ ] lights they made [ __ ] to [ __ ]
with you when you listened to Pink Floyd
and you're on acid is where you see the
brilliance you hear that heartbeat
throughout their songs it matches up
with your heartbeat yeah all their music
has a heartbeat to it a rhythm and it
matches up with your rhythm and deep
into the trip you'll realize you're
breathing it's [ __ ] crazy it's great
I see what you're talking about even
with The Wizard of Oz because way before
the wizard war like my mom died they
came my mom died November 8th the war
came out a couple weeks after that and
one of the best songs in the wall his
mother mm-hmm it's a great [ __ ] so
unbelievable and Here I am a party I
would play and I'd have to listen to
this [ __ ] song and it was like Jesus
Christ did the you know it was a
beautiful Jam I mean I hate I think it
hits everybody I don't house amount oh
my god it just throws your [ __ ] feet
off you know but by that time by the
time I went to see the wall
I was already convinced that David
Gilmour was up there but what I would
I'm [ __ ] 56 years old I wanted to see
this concert when I was 17 okay what do
I remember from this night I remember
the lead-up Tony Ames cliff the lead-up
was one of the best things ever because
the wall came out tickets one on sale
and the countdown began and those days
it was likely I know we've been doing
lately well we're gonna kick it up for
this concert somebody's gonna die like
we were 17 and we had already decided
Jesus somebody's gonna die
the war was there vent in my hometown
like 80 people from that and the group
that we hung out with or went made the
trek to [ __ ] in the Nassau Coliseum it
was five [ __ ] nights so all of us
went you know to one of the particular
nights but that keep that album came out
maybe November 20th or something like
that that's all you heard there was no
Springsteen there was no Led Zeppelin
there was no Michael Jackson the city
was infested with the wall everybody's
how she walked into had was blown away
people were blown the [ __ ] away as big
as they were with thriller I'm telling
you the Christmas you were going to
people's house nobody even had Christmas
musical everybody was blown away by the
[ __ ] war and watch new year's head it
was just 40 days I never forget like we
were like now we're going into deep deep
territory acid every night
[ __ ] formaldehyde [ __ ] crystal THC
it was for five nights a week getting
ready for this [ __ ] show how long how
long did it take for the album to hit
and we came out the eleventh was it like
a week two wheeler Helen that day
everybody was that dissipated he he
[ __ ] did an interview where he said
something about you know I like playing
but I hate the [ __ ] people
that's how arrogant Waters is because I
wish we could play with a wall in
between us he made that statement like
in nineteen [ __ ] 75 and the name of
the arm is the wall it's about him
growing up in eastern Germany doing
[ __ ] Hitler or something
it's a [ __ ] how do you say how do you
classify Joey's in an opera is it now
it's a [ __ ] work of art yeah it's and
it's and everything and you have to see
the lead up to it like they just didn't
[ __ ] take four years off and get a
house in Jamaica and buy a pound of coke
hey if you look at that hits it was 75
76 78 79 and it was five five four
[ __ ] hounds that will remain the
greatest albums of all time
I mean Stevie wanted to put out three
albums and he released songs for the key
of life which is [ __ ] brilliant I can
name a couple artists but it'll never
happen again you know I don't want to
sound like that old guy that's putting
[ __ ] down but it'll never happen again
look at the release date for those crazy
thing wish you were here came out right
that is then that's that might be the
most recognizable song but it's the
worst song on the album you got you
kicks it off with shine on you crazy
diamond these five songs on the album
shine on you crazy diamonds which is
ridiculous for 14 minutes right and then
what and then wish you were here and
then have a cigar which is the jam right
and then welcome to the Machine and then
they close it up with an even jazzed up
steroid version of shine on you crazy
diamond two of the songs of the same
song but one's different you know just
pumped up and different and again the
lyrics and all these things are
ridiculous
I mean it's undelete what's the release
date so the Dark Side of the Moon came
out in 73 then wish you were here was 75
animals was 77 the wall was 79 hmm and
what was the album before the dark side
metal Dark Side of the Moon yeah before
the dark side in what was the UPSI
obscured by clouds metal metal and then
an atom of a mother
Adam Adam part of my mother yeah we're
good we'll come on
69 that's not a bad one I don't mind
that one I like metal metal has what on
it that's a metal has that one [ __ ]
jammed the one that they did live in
Pompeii
be careful with that axe Eugene might be
I think it's around there you got to
check out david gilmour live in Gdansk
tremendous he does a version of that on
you crazy diamond where it's just almost
all just him singing oh my god that
guy's voice these guys took care of
themselves side one is one of these days
a pillow of winds fearless San Tropez
Sheamus and on the side to only has
echoes echoes echoes the whole album is
echoes when they do echoes and that
pompeii stadium and he starts going
crazy and on that [ __ ] guitar if you
don't feel that's the people who you
know just just by animals just by
animals listen to the words listen to
the lyrics he's good I don't even know
his guitar like I can't even to me my
favorite album musically if his Gilmour
is animals yeah I think his guitar solo
in the beginning of dogs at the end of
dogs
I think sheep the work on sheep pigs the
guitar is [ __ ] brilliant there's only
five songs on that album yeah that's
what they did they just did their own
[ __ ] there was five on animals five
on wish you were here but the songs were
nine minutes you know at that time they
knew seventeen minutes so the first time
is pigs and it's a minute and a half and
then they have a 17 minute song dog goes
then pigs the first part on tattoo is 11
and a half sheep is 10 and a half and
that's it and there's another minute I
have to close it really and you know you
when he so they come off of the wall and
you know that they got the midgets and
the whole thing building the [ __ ]
wall there you are tripping on acid and
there's midgets and there's a plane and
there's all this [ __ ] but if I had to
define the moment that blew me away like
that moment that you like I'll never
forget this was when he came up on the
top of the wall and did the guitar solo
comfortably enough that was it and you
know what it's live on YouTube that
night I went the first night opening
night is on YouTube no they taped
somebody take those
put them on you do Wow so you can watch
all of them it's fuzzy it's shitty
quality but I didn't know you were a
huge man I mean they they you know I was
so depressed after high school I had my
you know I had a little case of the
broken heart you know all that missed my
high school sweetheart we had broken up
and I was just sad and out of it Pink
Floyd kept me going it was the only
thing at one point that I really had
that I loved it was just this love for
their music I annoyed all of my friends
all of my family annoyed the hell out of
them for years through high school and
after that when I moved out here to
California for the first time living
with my brother and he had a couple
roommates and they had this speaker
system in the living room area it's like
this four bedroom house or whatever and
man I would blast that shoves the first
one up I didn't care that I was waking
him up it was a beautiful California day
and Floyd's jamming and that's the did
set the tone for every day when I got
out here and it's just it's it's just
perfect music to me there's Pink Floyd
and then there's everybody else between
us I've gotten into some arguments of
people because I'll argue I'll get into
an argument with somebody if they want
to get crazy with the Beatles and all
that I'll argue it man I will go nuts
I've said it a thousand times my
neighborhood there was a lot of
[ __ ] said spec and all this
[ __ ] and there was never an argument if
you want to get into an argument my
hometown start talking [ __ ] about music
mm-hmm it was a [ __ ] argument that I
in fact yesterday I had Twitter suddenly
one of the tabasco's the last name was
Tabasco there was five of them hmm one
of the Tabasco said hey I'm friends with
Tabasco as they send their love like I
just talked the guy the other day they
were they were where I lived when I was
16 17 18 they were the neighbors to the
Rani's and the one brother thought he
was Eddie Van Halen you know but he
didn't play the guitar he just had no
long hair voilá cut that [ __ ] hand
you know as one of those Italian
families and they had five boys but we
would sit there and argue for hours
like he would go on his house irritated
cause he'd start with you know [ __ ]
ozzy osbourne they were like [ __ ] David
Lee Roth Ozzy and eat him alive yeah
Eddie Van Halen could eat up Tony Iommi
and then we'd start with [ __ ] Eddie Van
Halen how about David Gilmour and then
start squawkin in the water he'd start
paddling back but now now wait a second
yeah you know uh and I'll add and say he
was the best guitarist Andy Van Halen
Ravel revolutionized the guitar yeah
[ __ ] that
and then [ __ ] Randy Rhoads
revolutionized it again we just argue
for hours [ __ ] you you don't know what
you're talking about and then we told
Van Halen to with the poster of David
Lee Roth handcuffed and he's going the
house pissed off because that always
lost yeah you lost me with that you know
we've had discussions here when you know
people know what America is like before
John Lennon got shot every white dude
had a nice white privilege people in
those days all had an ace in the hole
you know like it was it was like you
know oh my god I just listened to Led
Zep from the song means the same it's
brilliant yeah go ahead and have a good
time on Led Zeppelin wait to the Beatles
get back together like that was every
that was white you know instead of
people you know I'm today they send
their stupid kids to school and that's
why privilege right that was white
privilege like that everybody was
shutting me and my friends down like
yeah yeah yeah yeah boots braced and
that would piss you guys off you like
talk to me the [ __ ] the Beatles and the
firt when John Lennon got shot that's it
those [ __ ] run away cuz the
Beatles weren't get back together now so
now those [ __ ] stop coming out
cuz they were about to take a beating
how the Beatles do it now [ __ ] ha ha I
don't like the Beatles now [ __ ] I'll
bring him like a Pink Floyd Albert's not
time for you to switch governments yeah
I'll never forget there was a mural of
the Beatles in the hallway by the way
about a month ago North Bergen high
school put on a performance and Aliens
yeah did you see how much [ __ ] my high
school got attracted for that when I was
growing up with those people were
disgusting the [ __ ] the stagehands he
still we to us he would get we'd sent to
him from Hawaii his name was mr. Pohlman
and he would hit me he might still be
there [ __ ] nah he was he lives in
Florida he's like a [ __ ] retired
jerk-off he was another guy thought he
was [ __ ] badass we used to torture him
- then we stole his shipment one time
that was the end or that robbed him for
everything one time I found that what he
would put that weed he was getting he
was one of those guys I would do this
[ __ ] I think we were in high school and
he had this little pack of [ __ ]
little [ __ ] nerds never do that
Hawaii thing at and then one day he
started talking about he had the best
weed in town and it really was it was a
Hawaiian week and they put it on the
stick with it with a string and they
mail it there was just a little stick by
31 to 35 bucks a lot of money in 1980
but he'd hide it you know in a bag and
like a doctor's bag with all his
paperwork and watch me fine Ana because
I watched him from behind the curtain
you know made though I'm a boy it was me
another guy they were thinking about
robbing but the other guy got close to
the suitcase and he had those
three-digit confirmations you gotta put
your number in there was one of those
whole school was a combination lock and
I'm like Doug we're going back old
school we're taking the whole thing
yeah well figure blow it up until the
paperwork okay and that's exactly what
we did you sophomore year the guy pissed
me you know like in those days when
you'd piss me off
I just give you some time I'd sit in a
bush then rob you and you especially
don't it goes out of town I'm stealing
those blob punks because he keeps
talking you know those guys I Got News
freaking wait till you come over yeah
wait till I come over you come up and
I'm going down the show for the weekend
there we go you got blonds call your
cousin's in Queens we got some new
speakers from because whether your
chances of ever meeting Lee's cousin in
Queens least we already got to speak
assault I would wait though Tony left on
the show he come back my house got
robbed with Coco I think I probably
still mad about that briefcase you know
I don't give a [ __ ]
we took the briefcase I don't even know
how we got out of the building
no do you remember how you opened it
oh I slammed it against the wall instead
the [ __ ] you think I opened
I was stupid for a while I thought you
know like when I was a safecracker I
wasn't actually like we one of those
guys that would sit there and like
figure out you can't you need 20 years
of experience an inside man as a teacher
I met an Irish guy he's like what are
you stupid
just take the safe to go sorry I always
had a dolly oh he's got a dolly in those
days
you steal a dolly because you never know
when you might get the call for the
morning you got a dolly [ __ ] ready to
go hey having that Dolly's next to
[ __ ] 200 yeah but how do you hide the
dolly like how do you give them the car
in your garage [ __ ] okay but when
you're walking down the street with a
dog I just saw some guy delivering
[ __ ] boxes you know this type of
people you grew up with these absolutely
in Youngstown nothing but you couldn't
find a dolly everybody would everybody
would just take them you couldn't find a
dolly
at least steal those look great great
the the check from a restaurant in the
eighties we would steal those things
people give you a check of the Chinese
restaurant billet raise the tray where
everything is all right there you see ba
ha ha ha ha the old days the Chinese
restaurant when people would give you
those if you went to somebody's house
and they had one of those and they had
rolling papers and weight on it how cool
you you robbed a Chinese restaurant
it is cool I've never even seen anybody
do that yeah you got a rob has enrolled
one joint on it he rolls it on the
tables take a big girl you know what
life is do you rob something you walk
out this is pretty easy with newspapers
Chinese takeout Bob Paul bird dog he had
like 20 of those two he had just gotten
a delivery you know he was talking [ __ ]
he was in the hallway do another [ __ ]
and I see them shoot down to the
principal's office dog and he had a
bunch of little [ __ ] gardeners around
them like no [ __ ] and I had I went
and then I just took the briefcase and I
think I went out the back door that was
like I stay away down
ja I walked out there with that little
briefcase nobody [ __ ] song had to
kept in a winter giant I'll remember
exactly what I did but I opened it up on
the side streets
it was like an alleyway I slammed it
against the wall wouldn't open then I
had a pocketknife I stabbed it I opened
it up I took the way that there's a
bunch of grades [ __ ] papers and I just
drew it a [ __ ] garbage
two days way the people were asking me
here mr Palmer got robbed somebody stole
his wheat he couldn't say nothing
because he was a school teacher
every time I see him I get one of these
anything I got second hang low whatever
that I love whatever the [ __ ] does
Hawaii say and he knew was me I tried to
there was a couple peaches Tony hints
clear you know I am very uh like I'll
get you just give me time I'll catch it
just a couple teaches from my high
school that won't friend me I'm pretty
but the most notable is camel breath
McGrath
mr McGrath and me bro we used to go
circles we used to get coke I used to
get him booze and [ __ ] what grade was
this right when I go up I was friends
with McGrath since ah his freshman year
he used to smoke a camel with no filters
so we scrub camel breath his cigarette
was orange his fingers on a [ __ ]
orange on the inside he always smelled
like having heavy Camel cigarettes and
he was the running back coach and we
became friends you know over the years
and then he became the driver ed teacher
so what I would do is I would go told me
it's gonna sign up for 10:45 Drive right
Lee sign up for 1045 hours so there's
you get this sign all three of us up so
the first one at school sign us up when
we were login and Carla McGrath
little by little we would just work um
psychologically in the same like you
know for the first month it was us three
and they go you guys are all right and
then when you do is the classes were 42
minutes so you got behind the wheel for
12 minutes three people and then he had
a steering wheel behind his thing
Cadillac made the car specifically for
our high school two cars not
specifically for ISO driving it and the
drive is it
it's a little by little we have we used
to make them wantonly abnormally told
him the crime you know he would pull
into a driveway
he pulled the chance dragon in the
Chinese restaurant I always talk about
the Starling threat
you might we go inside and get a little
steak on a stick you guys [ __ ]
trouble I'm not supposed to so we just
started with that we got him to stop and
get past spareribs
we got him then in time when I'm missing
the graph you mind if we stop and get a
six-pack he would just look at us it's
10:00 in the morning yes
Toby as a piece ain't nobody get here
we'll give you one that's beer and a
half eats you're in for a beer then we
started buying six packs a packs and
then we just started and then I started
like I started leaving blow for him in
places like that he was those days I had
an aunt that's a riot I told my story
about Comedy Central and I would call up
say Joe Ryan I'm having a hard time but
I could sell some coke I'm gonna come
over and she'd give me like two grams of
coke and I give him a gram I'd leave it
on the steering wheel or whatever and he
would like make believe he never got it
so we were friends like that lightly and
then I robbed the high school me Russo
and this dude that Ringo robbed the high
school I quit high school but you when
she still found that Jersey but we
weren't really what we stole was a three
triple beam scales from the chemistry
department because they're big they're
40 apiece there was $69 brand new at
East West will you kidding me I bring
the house I'll deliver it for 30 20 I'm
take 25 you got it but we had that 50
scales every clerical desk on the scale
where kids would measure [ __ ]
chemicals and [ __ ] we would take him
three three people were taken one at a
time with a big sports bag one Sunday
night I go listen they got like 50 left
we'd better get him by the go on his hat
we went in there we took every [ __ ]
scare we walked home with three scales
by the time we sold him the balancing
was off because we had a karyam people
had to put the equilibrium back on him
his [ __ ] like that
and two days later McGrath came to my
house you gotta give after stuff back so
we gave back to the football jerseys in
the helmets and [ __ ] I don't know we
were gonna do it
we used we were just [ __ ] oh my god
and then me and him became tight and
then the day we were surprised I was
supposed to graduate like a week later
we were in summer school and one of all
the teacher friends one of my friends is
in a jam we went to his house to set in
the morning all right listen we were
[ __ ] up we robbed the coke dealer we
were doing coke since Friday my buddy
couldn't go to summer school so we got
him to come on we gave him a rocket coat
so somebody had to be responsible for
that money so I called Campbell breath
and so they I gave your partner two
grams or whatever you never pay this so
McGrath paid me and he goes by the way
that [ __ ] you gave me that wasn't
cocaine let me show you what cocaine
this he started taking about coca-cola
and he goes you know what I'd do beside
teach I deliver coke at night people
don't want Spanish people at the house
why nobody wants a [ __ ] Mexican come
into the house and yeah it's universe on
its own to make it look obvious so he
was the type of guy that put his suit on
and came over the house they pay a
little extra let him go right up
two weeks after high school ended one
night he took me to a party and he I
told this story he gave me a pill and he
goes it only eat half of it it was a
Paris blue at the time of Paris blue was
Paris's answer to the quaalude the
American quaalude okay so it was like a
little thinner tab crazy [ __ ] so I don't
know I think I said some about him on
the road and podcast
no he won't friend me and [ __ ] peluda
held money that I always part the money
he had a great Cavalier a Chevy Cavalier
app someone that I want to put a bed in
I was putting Batson with it the reason
I robbed a jewelry store when I got out
of high school is because I put a
Bennett with it and I couldn't let him
down we lost like $8,000 Monday night
with the [ __ ] Steelers against the
Cowboys in Haiti [ __ ] one you put
$8,000 well between parlays and straight
backs I was [ __ ]
what did you expect me and my buddies I
couldn't let mr McGrath
down he was minding me putting
them with you so how to rob the jewelry
store and I thought my so I'm gonna rob
a jewelry store if I go to jail you
gotta bail me out but if I get out give
it a game with my skull chain and this
is some crazy [ __ ] he's just an amazing
statute of limitation when they rob the
house gas station and what they had with
those books that you [ __ ] go over the
tunnel with Lincoln Tunnel that's when
it was four hours for the toll now it's
16 Jesus four dollars for the tow but if
you bought a book you got him for 375
right so I brought we wanted that safe
and had thousands of books I was just
giving him away like calling cards but I
would sell them to him for Coke I'll
give you four for a gram and he would
sell your coke on the bottom already
damage it the gram will come in a little
bottle yeah dude was over put it on your
[ __ ] finger - good old this Wow
high school has changed high school has
changed a lot my friends tony
Hinchcliffe glad to have you back on
yeah of course
I had John the first time I didn't
really know what was going on I just met
you I had just gotten back to the store
but the other day I was sitting there
and my stoned self one man you know you
came into my mind I thought about the
audience that I saw when you went to
Manchester
killed Tony and I was like [ __ ] Tony
aunts Clippers come along [ __ ] away
you know you changed a lot you've built
this up you've built this podcast up -
it's a [ __ ] it's a TV show in the
making
really and man sometimes you stream on
Monday nights we do the podcast early
and I'll watch couple minutes of it and
it's like a [ __ ] pad like I don't
think television can handle that anymore
no they can't and that's why are you
know so many people are falling in love
because they don't you know you don't
have these commercial breaks that break
up the energy of everything and you know
we read a couple ads at the beginning
and then they were in for an hour and a
half plus I mean it's just you know it's
the show that I always wanted to exist
back when I was starting at The Comedy
Store I wanted to you know everybody
wants a not necessarily a shortcut but
just a way to get respect from your
years you know and I mean get up there
and it's only a minute of stand up and
then you just roll with the punches
during the interview part you know and
you find out about real people and you
get to meet the people and the
difference between what they do as a
stand-up comedian compared to who they
really are
you know and I mean like you're a
veteran so obviously you're the same
during the interview part than you are
with the stand-up but sometimes you'll
see the switch in these people and
you'll find out that the character that
they thought was funny isn't as funny as
their real selves and the real things
and I asked them questions and they
don't realize it sometimes but they're
kicking out better material during the
interview part than they are during
their stand-up part and it's just you
know it's a super comedy show man we're
watching comedians do comedy with
comedians and I got the band being
hilarious Jeremiah Watkins by a walk is
a one-man [ __ ] machine yeah he really
is I gotta take my hat off tool yeah
that guy cracks me up
all those young guys he cracks me up
like how Jim Carrey used to crack me up
when I was a kid and how you know I mean
just something that you love it's crazy
I always say it's one of my favorite
things in all of comedy and it just so
happens to be on my show is this band
with Jeremiah and Joel Berg
you know the drummer back there throwing
out these one-liners just out of nowhere
getting the crowd going crazy and it's
just a perfect storm of stand-up and
improv and fun you don't you show
reminded me I hope you don't get
offended the gong show yeah I was a kid
no yeah I've got another comparison gene
gene the dancing machine nothing made me
happier as a kid then watching gene gene
the dancing machine I would cry right
now
I would cry like if Gigi Gigi died from
diabetes the black dude it broke my
heart
gene gene the dancing machine was a fat
black there all right and virus would be
out there hosted also huh no way he'd go
you hear that not that tiny go it's time
for Gigi the dancing machine
you weigh like 300 pounds black dude
rather to get out and cook the pork
chops all his life but he don't give a
[ __ ]
then let him loose he's got a minute of
Fame and that damn and Jean Jean would
be [ __ ] dancing and then they'd have
to cut like they would tell whatever his
name was the hoes bear whatever I don't
know I'm not saying it right like listen
we're gonna cut he wouldn't give a [ __ ]
he just keep playing the music and you
see MBC trying to hold on like we can't
we got it Louis sponsoring but this is
so good
they would have the whole audience in a
[ __ ] if you ever got a chance look up
Jean Jean the dancing machine on the
gong show you will [ __ ] die just just
they would go off TV would go off so
that's what that's why I was thinking
about the other day I'm like it's time
I've crashed our audience in Manchester
yeah I know it's time for this to go
somewhere this needs a [ __ ] hole yeah
well I mean what they can't touch it
right see that's the problem when you
get some college kids to come and go
well right now it's 17 percent there's
17 to 32 year old so you got to put
Oasis on here or whatever the [ __ ] it is
that's when you ruin the show yeah if
they let you just do it like just listen
come in we don't care you light this
place on fire every week I took we want
television needs to be lit on fire again
I'm not being disrespectful late night
is horrible oh it's unbelievable it's
unbearable yeah at late-night television
and guys I've tried I know you critical
of me for saying it is horrible I love
the one guy you know because I knew him
when he were playing the guitar and at
the improv
him and his manager were nice people uh
Jimmy Fallon Valley yeah I can watch it
if it's a good guest and if it's Whitney
you know something like that but it's
not like I don't know why I figure is
I've been sitting there going
who the [ __ ] watches late-night right
who would stay up to watch Jimmy Kimmel
but that's a sleeping pill I mean it
usually take a [ __ ] XANA yeah it's
crazy when the English got all yeah take
the [ __ ] zanuck yeah it's unreal you
know
at us in the beginning like I don't know
13 14 15 years ago you know he hit Ohio
hard because we're like what the man
show guy got a wow this is cool this is
like a corporate chance he was like the
underdog and now you see how he just
phones it in sheds those tears you know
those you know gets emotional on purpose
he's one of those guys that can make
himself cry I've told people for years
that I would love in part to go on the
road once a month and do this show five
days a week what scares me is the
consistency you know wait my TV is four
[ __ ] nights a week four nights a week
I have to be funny to the American
audience that's very tough guys yeah
good luck good luck I know you want to
do it on your own but good luck four
nights a week you need some writers you
need two of your best friends to take a
job and throw material action ideas they
gotta be watching the internet you know
and they're just it's tough to be
consistent so I do give them that nobody
could be twenty four nights a week 52
[ __ ] we see it it's impossible not
every shows would be oh they're writers
these writers rooms are filled with
people they have I think Kimmel is like
twelve fourteen sixteen writers in
different rooms they don't even
communicate you know what I mean they're
all separate and then they have to send
in these files and jokes as the day goes
on like it's like you still got a lot of
clothes to write I will not anymore cuz
they all know I'm not doing it you know
do it but back in the day yeah I mean I
I was very lucky you know I left a
little bit of an imprint and got some
really great jobs now I don't do
anything I just I Drive right for The
Comedy Central Roast once a year even
that job literally they know that I get
burnt out and that I'm having too much
fun so they'll just have me come in the
last two weeks clean everything up get a
fresh set of eyes on everything and and
if anybody gets added last minute which
always happens usually the most
interesting people you're Dennis
Rodman's and you're whatever is you know
what I mean Martha Stewart I'll come in
and really you know open up the playbook
and write something in their voice
that's fun but that's only because I
love to what you were saying earlier
about about taking a break you know here
and there like that's sort of my way of
taking a break is taken a the roast
writing job a couple weeks out of the
year usually during the summertime and
it lands perfectly you show up bay at
11:00 and you're out at 7:00 and you go
do spots but I get to think in somebody
else's mind instead of my own what would
be good for my stand-up I'm thinking
what would how would Martha Stewart say
this and how can I you utilize her voice
it's like I'm still being and still
writing jokes I'm still thinking funny
business but from a different
perspective so that when I come back to
Tony Hinchcliffe two weeks later even
though I'm going up at night anyway but
when I'm really starting to write again
for whatever I want to do it's like you
know refreshing because I'm I'm back to
me do you believe I mean listen I
started July 18th of 1991 for the first
six months I [ __ ] around then I won
this contest and I became a host had a
place once a week I got to meet staying
up a bunch of the people I got fine
after a year and a half it was time for
me to go you know that that was long
enough that I fired from the broker
uh-huh I pushed one of the managers
again books fell down and [ __ ] he didn't
really the original manager that hired
me have left in their highs another guy
did one comedy he wanted something else
on Tuesday nights in but after I left
the broker I went to New York for a
while and in New York I learned the ins
and outs after nine months and I learned
what it took to take me to the open mic
level to be an open mic or in that farm
team you know the open mic thing and
after that I [ __ ] hit it like October
of 89 t32 I'm with a long as y'all came
up I didn't stop doing spots every night
like I slowed down a little when I came
here but not really because I had to
watch more TV because I was going on
auditions so I would tape I can ypd blue
and then come home at night and watch it
but I didn't know what television was
you know sorry
but now after 20-something years that
you know when you first start Comi
you're a single guy you could give your
life to it you know I'm saying in your
case we have a wife and she wants to
spend time with you and stuff you could
be away three weeks a month right now
Tony you're at that age you have the
energy you know come home Sunday you
know go out Wednesday we'll ever had
your comedy show but that as time
progresses you pick up a family member
yeah and now it's a little rough you
know I'm saying you don't want your wife
up your ass you see what happened I mean
you have two choices in this and then we
all love comedy I love doing comedy but
I love my family I love that today
before I came here my wife made chicken
cutlets and mashed potatoes and my
daughter prayed and now they're at a
[ __ ] uh at a [ __ ] playdate you
know I'm here with you guys you know I
have a schedule I can only go out two
weeks a month and that covers my spread
as far as me giving you the best comic I
could be if I want three weeks in a row
that third week there's gonna be cactus
I'm not gonna be me I'm worn out the
flights I'm 50 [ __ ] six you know you
could just do enough cryotherapy z-- and
this and acupuncture you still try it
today I woke up and [ __ ] seven with
the girls and they went somewhere and I
[ __ ] took a nap till 12:00 I totally
that's rare for me but I also took
[ __ ] two [ __ ] flights I went to
Buffalo last week came back and I went
into the city so you have to take a
break to learn to appreciate other
things there's some comics who will go
out puts the remonstrate and then stay
in for nine months make a bunch of money
for three months straight work like an
animal and then stay home for nine
months I don't want to do that no I want
to be in the game every month yeah I got
a schedule you have a sketch I mean you
call it from Monday through Sunday you
know you know yeah unless I'm on the
road on the weekend yeah you call it
from what coast to coast
yeah called me sure didn't like with
cherry pickers yeah I learned early she
didn't like cherry pickers you know I
work Thursday and Friday and Saturday
yeah she wants you there on Tuesday
jacking it up and that's what she look
at Oh called in for Monday this
we yeah so I would just call them
coast-to-coast I'm a big believer in
that I think that if you give it if you
give them the choice that you'll get
you'll get more you feel like you put in
for you put in for Tuesday and Wednesday
you're more likely to get Friday and
Saturday you know and I mean if you're
putting in yeah [ __ ] you called it
that's for a specialty I'm still
convinced she's running everything like
I think that building and the way that
it communicates I'm one of those weird
guys that really believes in the power
of the Comedy Store like I think the
place is so magical that I think that
whatever you know however it works
whoever is revver look appears to be
running it it's still just I still think
she's so powerful that she left that
imprint there there's places that you go
to as a comedian performer whatever the
[ __ ] you want to call yourself that you
could feel energy that something
happened in that room mm-hmm
something happened in that room I
watched the the leather skin of
documentary and they go back to that
studio and the guy feels the wall the
Comedy Store
something happened now people have
developed their people have become stars
out of there there's a weird energy
there the energy you know growth I have
that energy back now cuz I stopped going
to all the other places I love you Joe I
love everybody but I'm not going in all
the places I'm in the Marines yeah and
Marines hang out with other [ __ ]
Marines okay
the Marines don't go hang out with the
[ __ ] Coast Guard yeah at the Laugh
Factory a little go hang out with the
[ __ ] you know the cops Cub Scouts at
the improv and the Marines hanging out
with [ __ ] Marines I'm not putting any
other club down I'm just telling you
what I see and how I see it I look
forward to following runway yeah I look
forward to following Joe Rogan when I'm
gonna show that's not high level I tend
to change so I always want to keep the
stakes high hundreds and that's what the
Comedy Store does for me that's why I'm
having brother shows on the road since
I've dedicated myself to the Comedy
Store again what comedies improved the
other 50% because the confidence is
there yeah you just follow Chris D'Elia
[ __ ] oh yeah
you died but you got a lesson you got
your head handed to you go home and
figure I know how not to get him to take
it by crystally and it happens you
follow crystally it's a death
Ali Wong might go off you know I'm back
to that I was going to other clubs that
were less superior lineups so I would
drop my energy I would drop my god I
wouldn't take the set seriously I want
my heart to beat right I wanted to be
sitting there when that blue light
design and Tony hinge Koopas on he's
about to bring me up I gotta lose a
breath of fresh air it's like somebody
punched me in the [ __ ] side I have to
recover my breath again is I'm getting
up and you're saying [ __ ] about me
coming to the stage my Uncle Joe he
opened up for me in the special love
that my heart's about to blow out of the
chest that's it my dick can't get hard
yeah at that point he [ __ ] who's the
hottest chick in the world right now put
a [ __ ] in my face my dicks not supposed
to get on I'm ready for that stage yeah
and that's what I think the Comedy Store
I was watching that Tyson documentary
you've seen that Tyson documentary on
Netflix I was rewatching him for the
second time yesterday and he was talking
about his what he was literally thinking
when he was walking to the ring supreme
confidence nobody can touch me as I get
closer to the ring I'm getting more
confident by the time I'm in the ring
I'm an animal and nothing can stop me I
feel bad for my opponent I'm looking him
directly in his eyes the second he looks
away I know you know it's exactly the
comedy when you hear that [ __ ] Jeff
Scott piano or you see the light go on
for the guy in front of you and the
[ __ ] here we [ __ ] go literally you
know it's [ __ ] the energy it's almost
impossible to contain we all have our
own little ways we're all playing it
cool yeah I know yeah but man it is game
time in the band the more you the more
you want to [ __ ] you know all the
work that you've done the bigger here's
what's great about that place is the
greater you are the more it pushes you
back right so it's like all the sets
you've ever done that you're putting
that on your shoulders it might be these
people's first time seeing you you're
right they just saw bing bang boom Bing
boom right and then they've heard of
this Joey Diaz they've heard of this
Tony Hinchcliffe they're at The Comedy
Store but they've already seen great
stuff at this point they're thinking
they know what the hell is going on
their thing it's not gonna get better
than that that guy's my favorite I
already decided and then BOOM
got to come in and shock the world you
got a shock them back up to thinking
nope I'm the one you're gonna think of
first tomorrow when you wake up you
think about the night you have eyesight
at the Comedy Store
I'm gonna be first let those guys be
second oh you would go on the road and
kill all weekend and go back to the
store and Tuesday the bag of dicks and
check yourself like what the [ __ ] just
happened
always [ __ ] destroy all weakened
people by the people closest to me bust
my balls my wife doesn't but my
next-door neighbor some of my closer
buddies they go Tony why do you always
put him for Sunday because I've always
you know there I'm always would you do
today
bah bah bah bah how about you I flew in
from Papua every single Sunday pretty
much right I take off one or two a month
what weekends and and the oh why do you
put in for these Sundays you just did
you know five hour-long sets one on
Thursday to Friday to Saturday why you
doing 15 at cuz it's that's that's where
it's built right there it's built on
Sunday nights 15 minutes and you know
what else I do eight minutes on the
Monday nights I put my name in that
whole bucket thing that they pre they
pre put everybody's names and then at 10
p.m. they start pulling names and they
make a new lineup
unless I'm number 16 or farther back I'm
going up I'm working the newest 8 I'm
taking the chances of the thing that I
thought of in the car ride three days
later that I said I was gonna try that I
didn't try during the weekend I'm trying
it there those Monday's those little
eight minute sets are priceless and the
Sunday's same thing that's where the
real works done you get it right I told
me today we had somebody in here the
other day and she was talking about how
I used to host on Sundays I was my
lighter yeah I became a nice to host in
front of her I used to host the
showcases Wow
I'm the [ __ ] showcases it's a big
deal it's it's just to go up and front
of her for her to give me direction why
she was in between sets you would call
me over and whispered things in my like
that Chow bring up this idiot and
[ __ ] blow up the stage before it
might want to pass him I don't need
another spots in here she would say yeah
you know I don't need another [ __ ]
Mexican and they had Jesus Christ all
the impacts are gonna come now everybody
wants to be Carlos you know she would
say things to me but it wasn't that it
was me performing if I never took that
fear away that's it there's no more Kurt
this is the worst you could bomb because
she doubled is your mom and the talent
coordinator you don't saying she doubled
so she gave me a mom's love but she also
[ __ ] let you have it that was a
horrible job unless you put my stomach
goats and let the air out so yeah every
time you bombed the store when she was
around you drove home and you'd want to
crash into the pollen fountain like if
you bombed in the main room and you were
walking around you saw her in a chair
you just went right to your [ __ ] car
and you put your [ __ ] car to go it
can you imagine that was nice you tried
you didn't know what she was coming in I
was afraid she was gonna fire me she
wasn't really watching sets when I got
there that much at all but I was afraid
she was gonna fire me as a phone guy
because because I was the phone guy and
if you missed a call you know I'm
sticking my head up all second-floor
window Oh every single day she called
once every two hours
ain't Tony is timing there she would
always be looking for the talent
coordinator to make lineups or whatever
when when's he coming over but I mean
there were times in which I run say I
had to go use the restroom or something
you hear that and this is old school
again it's like there wasn't portable
phones at the Comedy Store these guys
didn't even have they didn't even have a
computer in the room right they had
nothing so it's like you had to get here
that phone you and you had to run to get
it so if you're smoking a joint he went
down the down the back stairs and taken
ahead of a joint you hear the phone you
had to book it hopefully get it by that
fifth or sixth ring if it's her you know
it was a telemarketer they're really
well they had telemarketers in 97 who
worked their heads Michell me Shaima and
I was also hold a brother
I took Freddie Saunders job so I doubled
as the runner mm-hmm me Bob Oh Shaq
would switch the job and then I would
[ __ ] host on Sunday nights that was
my income and I worked the door while I
was opening yeah
same and five for the door and I would
host that I would do my spot bring up
Eddie Griffin and give it to God virus
let him hold the same exact thing I was
Tommy gave it to me quick
when I became a door guy there almost
six seven eight months later he had me
hosting on a Monday night back when they
used to have it on Sunday and Monday so
I'd host a Monday and then two weeks
later I'd host another Monday and then
all of a sudden I'm hosting a Sunday so
it became a regular thing and that's
really where the kill Tony Carter came
from because those comedians were doing
three minutes and the thing that I would
do that other people wouldn't do was I'd
make fun of them after their set but the
other thing I would do is if they had a
joke that I had the answer to if that
makes sense fight a note a good note
that's short and sweet and you know like
I would I would say it into the thing
instead of saying Kurt Cobain for that
jokes a squirt Cobain you know what I
mean or whatever they were talking you
know just a weird example but it's like
I'd give them an actual note from up
there just a thought you know just say
that maybe just a thought you don't have
to take a moment to anyway your next
comedian you know what I mean so it was
sort of like it became sort of like a
roasty show that was sometimes
educational and then I've everybody was
telling me to start a podcast you know
six seven years ago and I was thinking
in my head like well maybe what about
live because I like an audience man you
know the the podcasts where has a little
crowd like legion of skanks do that they
do it and they have like you know ten
people that come to the bar and you can
sort of get the laughs like it's like I
feed off of that the normal regular
podcast sometimes I get a little
tightened up because I'm listening and
I'm daydreaming you know especially a
guy like you or I could just sit here
and I'm just basically just a fan
listening but there's audience members
and it's like hey you know so I built
the thing live around it but yeah it
started because I was an MC in Kill
Tony's basically just instead of three
minutes it's one minute and I
interviewed the people add a little bit
of that Howard Stern old school
interview element I always loved his
interviews way back was one of my big
things and so I try to use my gut
instincts to ask the questions and
figure out what we can get out of these
people and yeah I now you announce the
world tour yeah yeah a couple weeks ago
yep we're going everywhere
who's telling me you guys are going on
what your [ __ ] place it's chaos you
know we just got back from Europe but
now we're doing all the cities that we
haven't gotten to do yet that we wanted
to do Vancouver Seattle I mean
everywhere Chicago New York City
Gramercy Theatre in June I mean
everywhere Madison Minneapolis Milwaukee
Spokane Seattle Portland all these
places that have wanted to kill Tony
they're getting it where can they get
the bait set
Tony Hinchcliffe calm or death squad TV
and yeah I'm doing a lot of stand-up
comedy - we're doing La Jolla I'm doing
the store there and you know everywhere
Tony Hinchcliffe calm for tickets for
those things I'm happy you made it on
today I've been watching you for the
last couple years and you journey and
it's been inspirational and talking to
you I didn't know about that you got
killed Tony from doing that of the
Monday night that's brilliant that's why
I love you I think that's what I'm happy
you're in the game thank you and thanks
for being one of the Great's and
inspiring man you're one of the [ __ ]
rates I watch you and I [ __ ] die
thank you very much for taking the time
Thank You Jay I want to thank you crazy
[ __ ] for listening and follow
Tony Hinchcliffe on Tony Hinchcliffe
comm hmm all right that's [ __ ] it
leave what's the story you're right I'm
great I don't hear nothing I love you
[ __ ] I want to thank Tony
Hinchcliffe I want to thank the
[ __ ] I want to take all you
people for listen don't forget this
weekend not this weekend May night of
April 19th I'm at the beautiful theater
in Minneapolis which is sold out sorry
about that before 20 get ready to bring
the reef I'll be a [ __ ]
Milwaukee I got that Jeffrey Dahmer oh
gee I'm bringing up to that [ __ ]
for 20 we added an extra show go for it
we're gonna have a good [ __ ]
time but before we go the Church of
what's happening now was brought to you
by the teeter inversion table let me
explain something to you
like I told you in the beginning this
weekend Pittsburgh was phenomenal but my
back was killing me when I got home my
wife cuz you don't even need to go to
the chiropractor let's try out the
teeter inversion table like I said it
sounds strange but hanging upside down
is great for your back when you're
upside down it takes the weight off your
spine and that releases the tension in
your shoulders your neck and your joints
all over your body
tina has helped me with my back pain
just those two days there huh man
you too and even if you're not getting
aches and pains like an uncle Joey
but you workout train or do yoga a DAT
either to your routine it will help you
recover faster and help your body in
alignment if you work a job where you on
your feet all day or you work a job
where you sit all day a teeter inversion
table will help keep your posture and
your joints healthy you gotta take care
of your body guys look at me it looks
like the steroids backfired you
understand me
no matter what your situation you'll
feel better and to hang upside down it's
fun plus it's small enough to fit in
your apartment or your office I love
this thing I've done my homework and
this is the best inversion table on the
market guys they've been hanging up
people upside down since 1981 and with
three million happy customers you know
they got your back now what I'm gonna do
for you is this cuz I love you people
and I want you to be healthy teen
inversion tables have thousands of
reviews on Amazon with an average 4.9
star rating and they have a special
offer just for you Church [ __ ]
savages for a limited time you get seven
dollars off a teen inversion table plus
one hundred dollars worth of bonus
accessories where you gonna get that
action from the church so go to Tina
calm slash Church i'ma tell you what
else I'm gonna hook you up with free
shipping free returns and a 60 day money
back guarantee no risk to try it out
remember you can only get $70 off a teen
Immersion plus free bonus accessories by
going to t TOCOM slash church that's
t.com slash church get upside-down you
bad [ __ ] you're gonna be
thankful you're gonna be thankful you
ordered this also representing the
church is my favorite of all time on it
why because like PETA like all the other
companies that bring it I bring a you
they back what they talk you follow me
alpha brain one of the best products on
the market for you neurology
neurological whatnot if you don't like
it it don't work for you keep it I don't
send you back the money plus they got
the shrimp tank plus the shroom tech
immune plus the shrimp export listen
you're flying you're trying to recover
you want more oxygen shrimp tech that's
the way to go the protein powder the
supplements are on it of the real deal
Mongolia Phil I can't help you out with
the kettlebells are the bats when they
yeah you're on your own there but as far
as supplement Joey got you whether it's
the jerky whatever you need I got you go
down a dot-com right now and press in
church and get 10% off your first order
delivered right to your house you
understand me so listen I want to thank
Tony hitch cliff I want to thank the
[ __ ] I want to thank on it I
want to thank Teague inversion table but
most importantly I want to thank you
guys for a great week
Tony Hinchcliffe Jennifer Pryor you guys
are great
but most importantly you guys for listen
I love you guys I'll see you Monday
morning early tip top Magoo ready to go
stay black Lee kick this [ __ ]
meal